which is why the matrix was redesigned
to this the peak of your civilization in
1989 the Cold War ended in 2001 the twin
towers fell but in between was an era of
relative stability for America the
economy soared politicians balanced the
budget and the president played sax on
Arsenio even the Simpsons saw the
stability happening during the 1990s
what's wrong with this country and a man
walked down the street without being
offered a job there's been plenty of
discussion about movies reflecting the
tragedy and chaos during the time they
were made such as monster movies showing
cold war anxieties and 21st century
horror movies conveying fears of acts of
terror but what about movies that came
out during a time of general peace and
security in other words how can a film
reflect stability maybe one of the best
years in film to explore this question
is 1999 not only is it the turn of the
millennia in the end of a prosperous
decade but that year also had many
movies that deal with the stable
uneventful world of the 90s let's see
what the most popular movies can tell us
about that unique moment in history this
is the world that you know world as it
was at the end of the 20th century the
90s were defined by more than just
stability in the present because of that
stability people very actively looked
into the future the dot-com bubble of
the late 90s and early 2000s provides a
great example of this forward-thinking
tech companies weren't being valued on
what they were currently worth but what
they could be worth we marveled at our
own magnificence as we gave birth
of course with those positive outlooks
also came anxieties technology led to
fears of the y2k bug the idea that the
switch to the year 2000 would crash many
vital computer systems and create chaos
it's actually what Peter has to fix at
his job in office space from here we get
what makes some 1999 movies so 1999 in
general movies released in that year
were not about surviving the present
because the present was actually going
well they were about being tired of that
stable present and looking for a
radically different future it's a timely
take on the hero's journey where the
call to action isn't caused by some epic
circumstance but from the lack of epic
and yeah what do you do there I sit in a
cubicle of course not all movies from
that year capture this idea especially
the genre movies and movies from a
different time period but the lack of
epic does exist in a surprisingly large
amount of them perhaps the most obvious
symbol of that boring 90s lifestyle is
from the recurring image of the plain
cubicle which shows up in many movies
from 1999 there are classic visual
reminder of the dead-end job a job that
may be stable but has no future and no
excitement it's from this powerful
visual that I affectionately named this
style of movie the cubicle movie but not
every cubicle movie uses a literal
cubicle to show this feeling The
Boondock Saints is a crime thriller
about the criminal underworld in Boston
but even in a movie so far removed from
corporate life it still clearly
showcases Rocco having that same
unfulfilled stable job as a package boy
for the mob so you don't have to have a
literal desk job to show this 90s
anxiety any character can be stuck this
way so long as it feels corporate never
changing and stable to the point of
boredom by grabthar's Emma
water savings it's not that filmmakers
were actively trying to summarize the
90s climate it's that every filmmaker
made their movie within that period of
time so that period will inevitably
influence the production the cubicle
movie has a premise based in that 90
stability so a significant percentage of
these movies create conflict out of a
very similar atmosphere it doesn't
really matter I I don't like my job and
I don't think I'm gonna go anymore
the product of this stability is also
monotony and monotony allows space for
introspection as a result a lot of these
films deal with identity and stories
about private lives American beauty is
about the inner lives of suburban
neighbors while the setting of the film
represents the idyllic American
landscape of the time the characters
represent the anxieties underlying that
pristine exterior both the families have
unfulfilled home lives the father is a
borderline sexual predator and the
neighbor is a secret white supremacist
who also happens to have repressed
homosexual feelings this movie
criticizes the perceived stability of
the era suggesting that it's simply a
mask that hides the true self the
flowers in the garden the couch and the
90s lifestyle are not true beauty but
rather mimicking beauty it's an
artificial American Beauty Fight Club
takes this opportunity for introspection
and turns it into a conversation about
manhood a world without conflict means a
world where men don't have a way to
assert their own masculinity so the
characters go to great lengths to
manufacture conflict and chaos to
satisfy their masculine impulses the
movie satirizes this way of thinking as
an ineffective and unproductive way to
find purpose even though the film was
intended as a cautionary tale many men
took it a bit too literally maybe the
satire was too relevant really the movie
reminds us that the stability and
uneventful nosov the 90s was largely a
middle-class white male phenomenon film
starring minorities or women like boys
don't cry and all about my mother show
us that for some people the 90s were
anything but boring and stable these
movies highlight the issues still
present underneath that stable suburban
exterior cubicle movies star men who
have so little conflict in their life
that they seek it out and they can only
really do so because they have the time
and the money and there's no movie from
1999 that expresses the ideas of the
cubicle movie more than being John
Malkovich the film exaggerates the
oppressive corporate imagery in films
like office space by creating an absurd
office with low ceilings here the office
literally bears down on its employees
when Craig discovers a portal that lets
you live in John Malkovich his mind for
15 minutes he uses it to escape his
boring life
he even monetizes the portal and it has
massive appeal to people who are tired
of their boring lives and want to mimic
the seemingly exciting life of a
celebrity
Craig uses Malkovich's status for sexual
gratification and career goals but these
shallow desires never lead him to true
happiness living the life of someone
else means he never worked to make his
own life better he tried to escape his
problems by mimicking someone else
instead of exploring what was within
himself Charlie Kaufman said he wrote
the film while he worked as a writer on
the TV show get a life the best part of
the show came from the scripts written
by its original creators so all the
other writers tried to imitate their
voice the results he said was extremely
unfulfilled not only because it wasn't
personal work but because mimicking
someone else inherently means that you
are not interesting enough Bing John
Malkovich and to an extent all cubicle
movies seem to reflect this idea in some
way social forces compel us to conform
ourselves into a certain definition of
success like having the good job and a
comfortable life but having to do this
requires the belief that who we already
are isn't good enough
I think cubical movies are trying to
remind us that we are worth it the point
is there doesn't have to be some crisis
going on for a movie to reflect world
events 1999 had this crazy phenomenon
where nearly a dozen major Hollywood
releases feature a main character tired
of the stability monotony and uneventful
nosov their life and it's a perfect
mirror of what America was like in the
late 90s the movies of that year
reminded people to reclaim their
confidence and search for a more
exciting and personal future in other
words they reminded us to party like
it's 1999
[Music]
to truly understand the production of a
movie you also have to understand the
time period it was made in another
classic example of history influencing
film is German expressionist cinema of
the 1920s not only should you watch some
of those movies but to understand them
better I'd also recommend you learn
about the impact of World War one on
Germany which greatly altered their
society and in turn their movies you can
learn more about that time in the
secrets of World War one documentary
available on curiosity stream curiosity
stream has recently expanded their
library of documentaries to more than
2400 titles about everything from
history to technology these high-quality
videos are a great way to broaden your
understanding of the world around us go
to curiosity stream comm slash now you
see it for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and nonfiction
series enter the promo code now you see
it when prompted during the signup
process and your membership is
completely free for the first 30 days
thanks for watching and thank you to my
patreon supporters who all got early
access to this video before the general
public